okay everyone I am so excited today
because I am joined by Morena bararan
who stars in Fast Charlie which is in
theaters and and man today how you doing
today I'm good how are you oh I'm doing
great I'm so excited to talk to you I
absolutely love this film so it's
another hit you're in which is exciting
I think people are excited to see you in
this movie with Pierce Bronson but what
I found so fascinating is you have a
great southern accent in this film and
you're playing this character who is a
Mississippi Woman now you being a fellow
New Yorker what was like the first thing
you noticed that was like extremely
different you had to tap into than like
your normal ways about things yeah I
mean you know first of all I had an
amazing dialect coach to monic and he
was instrumental and getting me up to
speak quickly and there I discovered
like hundreds of Accents in the South um
and in the New Orleans area the um the
Louisiana area a lot of different ones
as well and so we I listen to a lot of
different tapes of people people and
then I sort of picked one that was the
closest um to uh to my
natural you know leniency uh just
because I wanted I wanted it to not feel
so laborious and there were some
similarities between Brooklyn and
Louisiana accent I have to say um um a
lot of rounded out RS and like sounds
that like are also used in the East so
it was really cool to to to point out
the differences does it make it easier
doing accent into staying in character
or is it still at the end of the day
more challenging to keep having to stay
in a different accent than your
own yeah I I I find that really hard um
I prefer you know to you get into it you
practice and but also being down there
being in New Orleans being on location
was really helpful it became a bit of a
character in the film itself and like
really helped with the the mood and the
feel of it um and you're listening to
that all day long so you kind of tend to
absorb it as well but I don't really
work hard like in in between takes I
don't like like to stay in the accent I
like to relax a little bit um for me it
just feels like more work okay so you're
not method is what you're
saying I mean in some ways but not
really not you know I take like a little
sprinkling of everything I like that I
like that so what I also love about this
character of Marcy you play is that she
is a taxidermist so what I was wondering
watching this film are these real mounts
around you and did you practice any real
taxidermy uh yeah it was really
interesting right it's something that I
hadn't spent a lot of time thinking
about uh I I did some research I looked
at some websites met some women that
were taxidermists and then watched a
woman work on a a small bird on zoom and
it was fascinating um her shop was very
bare uh she was moving into a new shop
but it was all very very sort of clean I
it's I don't know why I expect a lot of
Gore and like body parts and things but
typically that stuff was been drained
out and cleaned out before you even get
to the the stage of putting them back
together so um that was a revelation and
then also just the you know the tools
used and the fine Artistry involved in
making something look alive again you
know the the the feathers tend to get
damaged or dulled um the the colors fade
um and then the eyes have to be painted
in to look more alive and so there was
like all these like Nuance things to it
that I hadn't thought about and it was
really cool to watch somebody work on
that no and it was super convincing like
you had been someone who's done it so
many times and I think it's cool to add
to your characters I think people are
going to like seeing that in the film um
you you always play characters too that
look great with tattoos so I was
wondering if you weren't an actress
would you be all tatted up is that
something you've ever like
imagined I mean I think if I want a
tattoos I can get them anyway I'm just
not a tattoo person it's not something
that appeals to me I I would stress too
much about trying to find something that
I would be happy with permanently oh
interesting okay so it's not like a
reason of like oh it would hurt my
acting getting certain roles if I had a
bunch of tattoos you don't think that's
like really as much a thing
anymore I don't think so I think a lot
of actors have tattoos uh they just
cover them up but I yeah it's not it's
it's just something that I have anxiety
about yeah no that that makes sense um
and it's cool because you have a scene
partner here with Pierce Bronson and
this film so being that that's someone
you probably watch growing up is that
still make you go wow being around him
on set do you still get that
feeling uh he's phenomenal and such a
movie star you know he's um somebody
that has a a large body of work and is
so talented and has played such iconic
roles um that yes I was a little star
struck when I met him and nervous and
you know he was so welcoming though and
and so kind and and and it really struck
me you know how even somebody as
experienced as he is you know he was
still nervous about certain things and
um working really hard on the script and
the lines and and the accent and it was
just it was really lovely to experience
that with him and he was so uh giving as
a scene partner and um I I felt you know
on equal ground with him artistically
and it was really it was a refreshing
experience yeah and that was my favorite
thing to watch in the film is this being
a two-hander and the chemistry you guys
had together and when you're really on
screen a lot towards more towards the
middle of the film I really really
enjoyed it um now I love that you also
this year played a character in
Assassin's Creed Nexus VR and that
you've previously done Destiny 2 so it
makes me wonder though in your life have
you ever been a gamer or are you a gamer
currently nope I've never played
assassin creen
I've
never been into video games my kids are
just starting to get into it um I it's
not when I was like 12 maybe you know
was like 12 or 13 was like when the um
Tomb Raider series first came out like
the very first basic Bare Bones one and
I remember being really into that but
mostly because I would just I like the
problem solving aspect to it but I'm not
I'm not definitely not to like shootter
shooter um first person shooter uh games
but you know in general you could tell
me about a video game or make one off
and I wouldn't know the difference ah
it's interesting it's cool though that
you're doing them because I feel like
more and more too it's like you see
bigger names like you doing video games
and people love to see it so especially
me as a gamer so I I love you do it um
also I want to bring up too on Instagram
you had shared three weeks ago that you
finished a half marathon congrats but
where my brain goes with that is you're
welcome but do people recognize you when
you're doing like a half marathon that
you got to be like you know hold on a
second I'm running a half marathon has
that ever happened to
you um I picked a course a little bit
further away um out of the city I live
in New York and I picked something um in
ter Town Uptown which was a good and a
bad thing I mean I was everybody was
very focused on their own you know time
and and running um but it was also very
hilly and really difficult so I was like
kicking myself for not having done that
research ahead of time for my first
marathon it was like a a really
difficult course um but no nobody nobody
bugged me it was it was wonderful oh
that's awesome so when do you think the
full marathon
coming
never oh come on it's gonna come I see
it you're you're on your way um so also
too you know everyone's pumped to see
Vanessa back in Deadpool 3 and it's
official news she's going to be in it so
how do you feel about like you see all
these like set leaks are happening and
everyone's talking about that is that
like just for you as an actress do you
feel like when you're a part of a movie
like this that you sometimes have to be
like in hiding in a sense or like when
you are part of the film that there's
this weird thing where you can't even
like be
seen no I mean I think you know that
movie comes with s such a huge fan
following but uh they're so secretive
about everything and I think most people
don't even know what's going on with it
which is kind of great um I I know I've
been allowed to talk about being in it
um so that's that's fine I can share
with people when they ask if I'm in it I
can say yes I can confirm I'm in it um
but yeah it's it's hard to like speak
about it because I can't be specific but
I'm so excited um that people so love it
care for it um and that it's something
that people are looking forward to yeah
and I I really think it's going to be
the movie of the summer so just as a
generalization do you think this is a
film that will get everyone like
instantly excited invested again in the
MC like will this be the thing that
pushes it back
up I hope so um it's a great script it's
a great movie so I'm excited for people
to see it I think you know there's the
the What's a what's the Ryan used this
term sequelitis third sequelitis which
is really you know it's it's a thing
it's really hard to like keep people
interested you're measuring up to two
other great films but um I think they've
done a fantastic job at at um measuring
up awesome I can't wait for it and I
can't wait to see vess again so I think
everyone's really excited about that
news um but everyone watch Moren just
kill it in fast Charlie which is in
theaters and onto man today thank you so
much for joining me hope talk to you in
the future one day thank you so much I
really appreciate it